Chris joins us now more pressure on
Notre Dame or Michigan in this game
Chris I think there's more pressure on
Michigan and Jim Harbaugh I just you
know you look at the timeframe of how
Harbaugh has been in Michigan now these
are all his players o'clock in the you
know in the armor in Ohio State the big
10 right now with the Urban Meyer
situation and Michigan's yet to really
have that standout season or big time
you know Final Four appearance at this
point right now so yeah I think there's
a little more pressure on Michigan at
this point if you were gonna handicap
the quarterbacks here because Notre Dame
loves to run with winbush and then you
get Shay Patterson who transferred and
comes in and so what do you expect
offensively in this game from these two
quarterbacks yeah I do think that this
has a chance to be an ugly football game
and not necessarily because of the
quarterbacks with because of the really
the great defenses I think we have in
this game Michigan's defense especial
there's no denying that I think Notre
Dame's defense is being a little
overlooked in this matchup because of
the star power on Michigan defense afar
that's the ball but I'm very impressed
with what I've seen from Shay Patterson
going back watching film from Ole Miss
he can make some jaw-dropping plays and
throws he's a special athlete he's got
very good see and if he turns the corner
he can turn the corner and run 20 30
yards up the sideline he's got a quick
release you know there's a there's a few
errant throws here and there that I see
mechanically but I was very impressed
with what I saw was Jay Patterson and
then as far as Brandon Wimbush Brandon
Wimbush is you know he's in the
conversation for the most gifted running
quarterback in the sport he does need to
polish up his throwing I watched the
spring game film you know there still
throws that you'd like to see him
consistently make that he misses and you
know I still think it's a work in
progress Dan as far as just his ability
to be that consistent thrower within the
pocket and they're going to need that
tomorrow night because I just would be
shocked with losing Quentin Nelson and
Mike look lunchy and don't get me
involved in this Notre Dame off
I still think is gonna be very good and
it's going to be a pain in the butt to
defend this run this run game that they
got but I just think with this front
seven in Michigan which I would argue as
you know top top of the nation you're
not gonna be able to rely on the run
game all game long you're gonna have to
make some throws some NFL type throws
into some type windows and be somewhat
consistent with it if they want to win
this football game who should win this
game oh I know who should win this game
it's about as toss-up as I of a game as
I've ever covered really I think that
Michigan should win this football game I
do I think if you just ask me who should
win it yeah I mean it's Jim Harbaugh
it's a special defense they got their
two running backs back from last year in
Michigan you know they are missing two
wreak black who is really probably their
most talented receivers that hurts them
but uh end of the day then I think this
is like a 16-13 22:17 maybe a 1310 just
slugfest type of football game Chris
Sims joining us course co-host pro
football talk live with Mike Florio and
he'll be there for pregame and post
content a kickoff 7:00 Eastern on NBCSN
tomorrow night it's Michigan and Notre
Dame these schools recruit you they did
I guess I could still remember I
probably enough I went to Notre Dame Bob
Davies is a head coach I went for the
spring game Urban Meyer was the guy that
was in charge of recruiting me so I had
a great time getting to know urban
through being recruited at Notre Dame
and then in Michigan I can still
remember Lloyd Carr in my family room
going gross over I'm telling you drew
Henson's gonna go play baseball
we need a quarterback I don't know if
that's a good impression but I tried my
best but that is I really wanted to go
to Michigan but I was scared of the drew
Henson situation it was a year old of
the main of course he was you know God's
gift to the world of football at that
time especially in the state of Michigan
and I felt like that was dicey so that
really held me back from that
how is urban as a recruiter amazing I
mean just you know Urban's just so calm
and cool and you know he can you know
for lack of a better phrase he can keep
it real he wasn't afraid to you know say
things that you might not like to hear
or whatever it was I I enjoyed my time
with urban I mean he he's a special guy
and you know listen I know this is not
the best look for him right now but you
know in my eyes he used one of the best
college football coaches in the history
of the sport
we had Lane Kiffin on last hour and I
asked him about the quarterbacking
situation at Alabama that is this by
design of what's going on where you have
Coach Saban has not announced he was
starting quarterbacks gonna be and he
said this is just about making sure that
the one who doesn't get to start doesn't
transfer there's still a chance that you
know if 2a gets the job and hurts
doesn't that hurts could still transfer
but how are you gonna be able to placate
both of those quarterbacks this year
yeah that's gonna be extremely tough you
know I would go with to uh you know
again I mean just what we saw her first
I think can get you you know nine I know
10 a no get you to the national
championship games all that the thing
that's always going to concern me about
Hurst is just would you play those
defenses that go oh okay we're not
scared of Alabama's physicality in their
run game we're gonna make them beat us
with the pass game I think that's where
we've seen the struggles there so he can
kind of feast on the weak from from that
standpoint but to a you know again it's
it's a limited sample size but pretty
impressed with just his natural throwing
motion and his boxy and in such a big
situation and if I was Alabama not that
I've studied them real hard you know me
I'm mostly NFL and then whoever Notre
Dame and Notre Dame's playing but I
would go to I think it gives them a
greater chance to you know keep it keep
it rolling down there in Alabama well
speaking of the NFL you had Tony Romo
doing press media for CBS's NFL package
and he said that it's Tom Brady stage
then it's gonna be Aaron Rodgers stage
and then after that it's gonna be Sam
darn 'old stage would you make it there
I I you know I'm not ready to
Sam Donald yet I do think Sam Donald has
some special attributes you know
certainly he's young still he's got time
to develop here his feet his pocket
presence his cool calm demeanor
I've been around Sam I mean New York
City the bright lights of media it's not
going to affect him one bit so that's
gonna be great but I will say this I'll
bring this question up for you or any
other Jets fan you know the one thing I
haven't seen from Sam d'Arnaud that I've
seen from all the other rookie
quarterbacks is just standing in the
pocket making Wow throws that's the one
piece I think that's missing from his
game it's what scared me coming at a USC
I really thought he was the worst pocket
passer of the whole group of
quarterbacks and I think to right now
and if you watch the jet game's Dan I
mean not too many throws down the field
not too many throws outside the number I
do think he's a worker and he can kind
of tinker with some of his mechanics to
fix those things so I'm not saying it
won't happen but yeah I'm just bringing
up you know a little food for thought
and one thing that does concern me about
his game have fun in South Bend tell
Liam and the boys we said hello and
thanks for joining us Chris thanks van
and I'll talk to you man B good night
sir Chris Sims NBC Sports
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]